pour clément steven dimitri et à l'exil
le déclic c'est l'école de production
leur avenir ils le voyaient plutôt floue
et puis c'est devenu net et précis
[Musique]
c'est la grosse pse on a levé en mixant
qu'on a fait j'ai c'est celle que je
t'avais j'ai l'habitude l'apparemment
mon amour maintenant puisque c'est la
plaie ses clients du coup apprécié à 17
heures
les turbulences des années collège sont
derrière alexis maintenant il sait ce
qu'il veut et où il va
depuis octobre 2010 est il prépare un ca
paix à l'école de production de besançon
une solution qui lui va comme un gant
l'apprentissage classique ne lui aurait
pas convenu honnêtement on goûte un mois
majoré
charest plus dans l'entreprise quand je
pense aussi
ils ont passé 2 alexis son cas lui avait
pas assez de maturité il accepter pas
aussi
enfin non soit répétée en alternance je
pense à des fonds respecte pas ferme on
respecte mon déraper un peu donc qu'ils
sont là pour nous tirer non pour
recadrer et qu'est ce qui fait que vous
acceptez justement d'être recadrés parce
que si s'ils font ça c'est qu'en
entreprise ça sera comme ça donc demain
ça sera comme ça une fois qu'on quitte
cette école c'est que ils veulent nous
apprendre dès maintenant ce qu'il faudra
pour plus tard donc c'est mieux
maintenant plutôt que d'aller dans un
entreprise et qu'ils n'ouvriraient
direct en école de production il y à la
règle des deux tiers un tiers un tiers
du temps est consacré aux matières
générales
et puis avait pas trop de fin à son
histoire sa un atout fait d'être dans
une école où on a peu de cours
théoriques mais où on y va cache où on
fait pas on n'écrit pas sur une feuille
46 line un quartier où au final il va
nous servir à quoi hautmont ivac h on
sait ce qu'on a à faire pour le saper on
sait ce qu'on doit apprendre et on a
tout le temps des thèmes qui reviennent
ou sap et à l'atelier alexis gère de a à
z une commande que lui a passé son
directeur un petit objet publicitaire
aux initiales de l'école de production -
l'école st
c'est pas que je faisais pas attention
à tout ça
j'étais dans ma bulle c'était je
travaillais pas pendant
et maintenant ici j'ai découvert enfin
c'est encore à l'école mais je découvre
un métier et aux pneus d'être autonome
et rigoureux
de faire que par soi même d'apprendre
mais en état de fait la méthode
d'apprendre à présent c'est un autre
ça vous convient
oui
c'est
exceptionnel exceptionnelle car alexis a
bien plus appris qu'un métier nous
apprend des choses sur nous que
nous ne savons pas quoi pareil non
être j'étais minutieux
ici il faut l'être encore plus pour être
rigoureux faux et tout ça je le savais
pas sur moi et là je vais découverte
wichita pion au quotidien sur du verre
c'est la fin de journée comme tous les
jours un des maîtres professionnelle
fait le point les phobies sécurité
qualité ponctualité
tout est repris comme dans une vraie
entreprise une rigueur qui est une des
marques de fabrique des écoles de
production
[Applaudissements]